is this fun is it
this is fun
it had all started in tottenham north
london
where mark duggan was shot and killed by
police
because intelligence suggested he was
carrying a gun
what began as a peaceful protest quickly
turned into civil
unrest
crowds of people stormed their own
communities
looters helped themselves to everything
and anything they could get their hands
on
and in the first riots organized on
social media
the police struggled to reclaim control
this is where i was standing when they
when they burnt the place down it was
just over there that's where the
window was that was broken where the
first puff of smoke came out
trevor reeves runs one of the oldest
family furniture shops in england
good afternoon during the riots it took
minutes to burn down
and many years to rebuild i had a phone
conversation with my father who'd come
back from
his wedding anniversary he'd got home
turned on the telly and there's his shop
in flames
in front of him on the telly i had a
phone call from him and he was
he was practically in tears i spoke to
my brother who came
came down here and we both stood and
looked at it you just feel completely
impotent and thinking
what do we do now i was seeing crowds of
people i was seeing
motorbikes screaming around on full revs
there was windows being smashed and
there was an awful lot of onlookers as
well
so you watched it burn yeah yes i
watched it for about half an hour
and then i saw a whiff of smoke come out
of one of the windows because it was on
the opposite side
to where i was that's where
the gentleman had leaned in and lit a
little sofa and
the rest is on camera for everybody to
see
the man who burned down the shop that
used to be on this site
was sentenced to 11 and a half years in
prison he was one of more than 3
thousand people
who were arrested over the course of the
riots and in the midst of huge public
anger in the aftermath
many of them would end up behind bars
vanell de laure was one of them he was
18 when he decided to throw missiles
into a crowd
and accepts now that it was a big
mistake
this right here is like where it
happened isn't it like clarence road
this is where i threw through about
got two three bottles on this road right
here and
judge made an example of me and gave me
a year for each bottle
over here was where the real madness was
going on like
there was thousands of people on the
street people from all over hackney on
the street like
it was insane
the atmosphere was like we need to send
out a message
we need to be heard because silence is
not working anymore talking is not
working anymore
no it's not like he wanted the police to
get hurt like
but it was it was like you don't need to
listen
so i need to change but professor tim
newbern who studied the riot
says nothing was done by politicians to
instigate change
and the lack of a public inquiry meant
the causes couldn't be addressed
more generally i think a sense that they
often felt that they were living in
communities that were
occupied communities by the by the
police and that
that relationship was often one that was
very hostile and difficult and dangerous
but then more generally i think it was a
sense of
impoverishment at times when they felt
that this was
not just an outcome of government policy
often but sometimes was perceived as
being a deliberate
outcome of public policy did our
politicians local and national
put in place things to to mitigate to
improve
by and large no no we saw almost no
response
of any real substance to the rights and
that's pretty scandalous
but it's understandable why someone like
trevor has little sympathy for the
rioters of 2011.
i think they could get away with it i
think that was predominantly what it was
it's a fun night out we can get away
with whatever we fancy doing
and that's really disappointing you've
got a very intelligent people
getting swept up in stealing bottles of
pop or whatever it is out of the window
but then you've got people who have got
nothing
who see it as an opportunity to get
something they'll probably never be able
to have
and they're two so such polar opposites
vanilla's actions 10 years ago have
blighted his life ever since
he's been stripped of his leave to
remain in this country and threatened
with deportation meaning he's not
legally allowed to work
he's finally turned his life around and
is volunteering
looking back on it i can understand that
he wanted to make an example out of me
but you're putting me behind bars
someone that's never been jailed before
someone that's fresh out of school and
you're putting me on the wing with grown
men
grown criminals i was still young and
impressionable
i don't know how you fought that was the
solution to the problem vernell sought
his own solutions
and now works with a charity to reduce
the chances of youth
[Music]
reoffending
the spasm of violence and looting died
away
almost as quickly as it had started
ten years on some of the victims and the
perpetrators
are still counting the cost of one of
the most violent
inner-city eruptions of modern times
[Music]
schmann freeman powell sky news